but the reason they like the guy is that
they're trying to be like Trump they
know that Trump is reaching out to these
middle American working class Union guys
that see that that like more of what he
does well I'll put it this way if you're
a dude hanging out at a hang out by the
grill with your buddies in the backyard
having a beer you are closer to Trump I
know it sounds shocking than you are Joe
Biden Joe Biden is so far removed with
his Rehoboth Beach Delaware upbringing
and whatever he was doing I don't know
riding horses and sing at the pool
having kids stroke his legs
Donald Trump while born rich and and
wealthy and all that is closer I'm not
saying he's close but he's closer to to
a dude who would hang out and have a
beer with you they need fetterman and
they need this kind of behavior that
comes off as as like more down to earth
well and you just saw Trump at the Iowa
football game Iowa over cyber State I
mean he was like he fit right in it was
like he was the grandfather of the The
Godfather of the fraternity I mean well
well done steak with ketchup yeah I mean
he held the burger up for everybody to
see but you know let's be clear why that
resonates with Democrats